-Performing "Presha,"
from their upcoming new album
"Welcome 2 "CalleGrove,"
give it up for
2 Chainz and Lil Wayne.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Whistling ]
♪♪
-Welcome to ColleGrove.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Pressure ♪
♪ Pressure, unh ♪
♪ Oh, she pressure ♪
-♪ Yeah, she pressure ♪
-♪ It be pressure ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ Special pressure ♪
♪ Yeah, she pressure ♪
-♪ Yeah, she pressure ♪
-♪ Ay, two BBL,
you know she extra ♪
-♪ Ooh, she extra ♪
-♪ Got that stank walk,
but clean as a whistle ♪
-♪ Clean ♪
-♪ In the kitchen,
scale, fork, and a pistol ♪
-♪ Shring ♪
-♪ Skrrt, skrrt, skrrt ♪
♪ Yeah, we cookin' now ♪
-♪ We cookin' now ♪
♪ You know this...pressure ♪
♪ 'Cause they lookin' now ♪
-♪ They lookin' now ♪
♪ Say, "Look out for me," ♪
♪ But they weren't lookin' out ♪
-♪ They were Lookin' out ♪
-♪ Got your...together ♪
♪ Suki, suki now ♪
-♪ Suki, suki ♪
-♪ More refills on me ♪
♪ You know we lit, lit ♪
-♪ We lit, lit ♪
-♪ They gon' run this back ♪
♪ Just like a Pick-six ♪
-♪ A Pick-six ♪
-♪ I done fell in love
with a T.B. ♪
-♪ A T.B. ♪
-♪ I done fell in love
with a rich, rich ♪
-♪ Talk to her ♪
-♪ Shawty know she pressure ♪
♪ Talkin' high blood ♪
-♪ Talkin' high blood ♪
-♪ Put two girls together
like a hybrid ♪
-♪ Like a hybrid ♪
-♪ You know I been trappin' ♪
♪ Since the dial-up ♪
-♪ Since the dial-up ♪
-♪ If they gon' hate,
then let 'em hate ♪
♪ That money pile up ♪
-♪ Man, it pile up ♪
-♪ When your friend call, say, ♪
♪ "Hello, pressure speakin'" ♪
-♪ Hello ♪
-♪ Towel under door ♪
♪ Saw that pressure reakin' ♪
♪ I done took a shroom
with that '42 ♪
-♪ With that '42 ♪
-♪ I done started whistlin'
like 42 ♪
-♪ Tell 'em ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Pressure ♪
-♪ Pressure ♪
-♪ Oh, yeah, she pressure ♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
-♪ Pressure ♪
♪ Yeah, she pressure ♪
-♪ Yeah, she pressure ♪
♪ Yeah, they pressure ♪
♪ They pressure, yeah ♪
-♪ Pressure bust pipes,
weapon talk nice ♪
♪ I only bust twice
'cause I'm so precise ♪
♪ Foreign run nice,
I'm goin' all night ♪
♪ I don't arrest her,
I read her her rights ♪
♪ I'm on that pressure,
she on that bass ♪
♪ I'm on that treble,
I'm on her level ♪
♪ She say her brother,
he got them birds ♪
♪ We ruffle his feathers ♪
♪ Watch what you tell us,
pressure cooker ♪
♪ Extra women,
got my section full of ♪
♪ Extra broke,
you can smell the boogers ♪
♪ Break your nose
like Devin Booker ♪
♪ All my women,
some second lookers ♪
♪ All my bros
got extra blickers ♪
♪ I got Nina, I got Maggie ♪
♪ And they both
got extra sisters ♪
♪ I be gettin' pressure
on the plug ♪
♪ I get treated special
by the plug ♪
♪ Feds puttin' pressure on me ♪
♪ I don't even sweat
in a hot tub ♪
♪ I be puttin' pressure
on my lungs ♪
♪ I'ma fill the whole blunt
with pressure ♪
♪ Like a stack
of a hundred ones ♪
♪ You gonna still fold under
pressure, lil' aaaah ♪
♪ Ooh,
pressure, pressure ♪
♪ Pressure, pressure, pressure ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-♪ Is it pressure? ♪
♪ Ain't this pressure? ♪
-♪ Yeah, this pressure ♪
-♪ I say pressure ♪
-♪ That's all pressure ♪
-♪ Who say pressure? ♪
-♪ We so pressure ♪
-Yeah.
-Thank you!
[ Cheers and applause ]